Okay, so welcome to this session on stress
across scale in cancer.
We are going to try to be very ambitious and cover
stress all the way across from the population level
to the organism level, to the tissue level, and to the
cellular and molecular level. And I think this really highlights
that stress represents different things across the
scale of stress. At the population
level, we are thinking about stresses and
survivorship and
inequity.
Then at the organism level, it's a lot about the stress
hormones, glucocorticoids, catecholamines, and how these
systemic stress responses, neuroendocrine signaling, and the
immune system is being modulated by stress.
And then these factors, of course, are affecting the tissue level with the
cells, the immune cells that infiltrate the blood vessels,
the extracellular matrix, metabolism in tissues,
and that, again, affects the tissues as the
cancer cells, the host cells that are responding to the different
stress in different ways. So we are going to
try to cover all of this in three talks.
That's going to be hard.
But I think it's really critical that we are thinking across
scale. Just as an example, some of the work I've
done, we had to think about how stress
is affecting the patients, how the patients get affected by stress,
how that leads to upregulation in stress hormones
affecting specific immune cells and fibroblasts and extracellular matrix.
And of course, that's mediated by effects on
the gene expression and the metabolic
reprogramming of the cells. So no one person, I think, can
really cover all of that. I think it's critical that we
speak to each other across disciplines to try to
help understand how stress is regulating cancer.
So,
we have selected three speakers for this talk, trying to cross
around from the molecules to the cells.
First, Ruth Shoresh-Jal from the Weizmann Institute will
talk about stress and mutation dependency, so cover
cells and microenvironment.
I will speak next about how chronic stress affect the systemic
immune response and the remodeling of tissues.
And we will end with Jesse Plaschak that will talk about
biomarkers in cancer survivors, and how they're responding to
stress. And hopefully this will all make sense and come together.
So with that, I'd like to invite Ruth to the
podium to start us in the smallest of the scales.
Thank you.
Okay. So, thanks everyone for
coming. Thanks, Mikala, for inviting me to this session.
I'm really excited to be here, because this session really
combines the two loves in my science, the tumor
microenvironment, and stress responses.
And so in my lab, as Mikala mentioned, we
are interested in stress responses in the tumor microenvironment.
And we view tumors as ecosystems in which the cancer
cells constantly interact with different cell types in the tumor
microenvironment, and it is through these interactions that tumors
progress and metastasize. And
one really fundamental question that I find intriguing, and
I've been looking at this since I started my lab about a decade
ago, is understanding really how are tumor microenvironments
created. So what makes a normal organ become a tumor
microenvironment? And I find this interesting because the tumor
microenvironment is considered to be genomically stable.
So unlike the cancer cells where there are many mutations,
this cannot be explained by mutations, but it should be
explained by other processes. And coming at it from
a evolutionary
perspective and studying stress responses and thinking about
stress responses and how they affect every process
in the environment,
we think that this is done, so this rewiring of the tumor
microenvironment is done by a combination of signals from
the mutated cancer cells as well as stress responses in
the tumor microenvironment.
So why stress responses? Tumors are stressful
environments, so all of these different pathways highlighted
here have been shown to play a role in the tumor microenvironment, and these
are some more molecular examples for how stress
responses mediate interactions between cells in the tumor
microenvironment, and this is already quite outdated.
This is from a review we wrote several years ago,
showing really how stress responses mediate interactions in the
multicellular level between cells in the microenvironment.
So the cells that we are most interested in in the tumor
microenvironment are cancer-associated fibroblasts or CAFs,
and CAFs are the most abundant constituents of various carcinomas.
Like other cells in the microenvironment, they're considered to be genomically
stable, so not rewired to become cancer-associated
fibroblasts through mutations, but through other processes that we try to
understand. And CAFs are heterogeneous at many different
levels. So they're heterogeneous in their origin, they're heterogeneous in
their transcriptional program, and they're heterogeneous in their
functions.And many subsets
of CAFs were introduced over the years.
We can kind of globally
diversify them into
myofibroblastic CAFs or myCAFs, which perform ECM
remodeling functions,
inflammatory or immune regulatory CAFs or iCAFs in short,
which mediate responses with the immune microenvironment.
Several years ago, our lab and others also showed that there are these
antigen-presenting CAFs or MHC class II expressing CAFs.
We are not really sure about their roles.
And then other subsets were introduced, for example, these
cancer-associated parasites or vascular-associated CAFs
that are important for interactions with the
vasculature. And so there are many different
functions, many different transcriptional programs, and we also know that
there are many different locations of fibroblasts within the tumor
microenvironment, and I'm excited to share this slide from a review that
Mara Sherman and I wrote together and just came online today.
So please check it out in Nature Cancer.
And, what we try to highlight here is that different CAF
subsets can be localized in different parts of the tumor.
So some of them are really cancer cell adjacent, some of
them are more in the periphery or perivasculature
region of the tumor, and some are even found in perineural or
in tertiary lymphoid structures.
So CAFs are heterogeneous. What we try to understand is what determines
this heterogeneity and what will make one tumor microenvironment
different from the other.
And several years back,
we showed that this is mediated in part
by cancer mutations. So mutations in the cancer cells affect the CAF
compositions. I show this here in breast cancer where
we looked at two CAF subsets that at the
time we termed pCAF and sCAF for expression of
podoplanin and S100A4, and we found that
the ratio between these two CAFs subsets is correlated with
disease survival in the patients.
But moreover, we found that it was correlated with mutations in
BRCA1 and II. So BRCA mutated patients had more of
these sCAFs, which are the antigen-presenting or MHC class II expressing
CAFs, and less of these pCAFs.
And we found that this was true not only in breast cancer, but also
in pancreatic cancer, where we looked at the three subsets
of CAFs, so myofibroblastic, immune regulatory, and
antigen-presenting. And we found that the
BRCA-mutated pancreatic tumors had more of
these red,
that you can see here hopefully,
clusterin positive immune regulatory CAFs.
So here's where we get back to stress.
So clusterin is a chaperone, and it's known to be
controlled by Heat Shock Factor 1, the transcriptional regulator of the heat
shock response.
And so we looked in these tumors also at the expression of
HSF1, and we found that HSF1 as well is
expressed more in BRCA-mutated tumors in the stroma of
BRCA-mutated tumors than in the stroma of BRCA
wild-type tumors. And in fact, it wasn't just HSF1, so we
looked at other transcriptional regulators of other stress
responses such as ATF4, and XBP1, the
regulators of the ER stress response and integrated stress
response. And we found that generally speaking,
BRCA-mutated tumors were more stressed compared to BRCA
wild-type tumors. This is again looking at the stroma.
But BRCA-mutated tumors have mutations also in the
stromal cells in at least one allele of BRCA, so it was important for us to
show that this is really mediated by mutations in the cancer
cells. And we used in vitro models and mouse models to show that
it's really the mutations in the cancer cells that affect the fibroblasts.
And cutting a long story short, we found that
this environment causes the fibroblasts
to become more immune regulatory, so more iCAF-like
than myofibroblastic, and this is in an HSF1-dependent manner.
So what this study showed was that the mutations in the cancer
cells can affect the fibroblasts, rewire their transcriptional
programs through activation of stress response
mediated pathways through HSF1 to become
more immune regulatory than myofibroblastic.
And we think that this is really exciting in its potential therapeutic
implications because we could potentially target
these stress responses in the tumor microenvironment, and we could
even combine this targeting with stress responses in the tumor
microenvironment with targeting of the cancer cells.
For example, in the context of BRCA mutations, PARP inhibitors
are used, and this combination could be a useful
therapeutic combination, and it could be also
effective not only in pancreatic cancer, but across
cancers that share these mutations.
So in the case of BRCA mutations, we find them in
pancreatic cancer, breast cancer, ovarian cancer, and prostate cancer.
So this could be potentially useful across cancers, and we
are looking into the therapeutic implications of this right now,
and this is still unpublished.
All right. But then we were also interested in understanding how general this
activation of stress responses is.
And so we took kind of a more unbiased approach where
we looked at those four tumors that I described before, ovarian,
pancreatic, breast, and prostate, and we looked at
different stress response
pathways in these
tumors. We did this using multiplexed immunofluorescence for the
transcription factors that are
controlling these responses, so looking here at HSF1,
NRF2 for the oxidative stress response, and ATF4 for
the integrated stress response or ER stress response.
And we found that generally, stromal cells that are
close to cancer cells are more stressed than cells that are
further away from the cancer cells.
So the closer you are to a cancer cell, the more stressed you
are.But we wanted to understand this in a more kind
of molecular transcriptional level, and so we used publicly
available data sets, single cell RNA sequencing, publicly
available data sets from these tumor types.
And I'm showing this here for breast, but we did this for the other tumor types as
well, looking at signatures of these different stress responses.
So the heat shock response, oxidative stress response, the
UPR, the unfolded protein response, hypoxia, and DNA
damage. And as you can see, there are different levels of activation in
different cell types. So there's a lot of data that I
encourage anyone who's interested in stress responses to check out this paper,
but just giving some bits of it. So again,
looking here at breast cancer, we can find that, for example, the
UPR is activated in B cells, the hypoxia stress response
is activated in
endothelial cells, and the DNA damage response is
activated in immune cells.
And we can also look at crosstalk between the different stress responses, which was
really what we were interested in understanding, whether there's a
network of stress responses and not just one stress response that is
activated. And so, sorry for the quality here,
but hopefully you can see here that, so here this
is again breast cancer, and we can see that the heat shock response is
coordinately regulated in different stromal cells,
so pericytes, endothelial cells, and fibroblasts.
The DNA damage response is activated in immune cells, as I showed you
before, and also coordinately regulated in the
stroma. But then when we look at the four different tumor types, we
can find shared and unique pathways.
So we see coordinated regulation of the DNA
damage response in immune cells across these different tumor types.
For example, we see the UPR activated in a coordinated
manner only in ovarian cancer. So there's a lot of data there, and I
encourage you to look at it, but we are interested in stromal cells,
and so we really wanted to see what is activated in the context
of the stroma, and this is not BRCA mutated, so HS of one
was not the highest one here. And what we found was that in fact the
oxidative stress response, and specifically NRF2, are
activated in a subset of fibroblasts, but not in another.
So in iCAFs but not myCAFs, and in a subset of
pericytes that we termed muscle per for activation of
pathways related to muscle functions and not
matripair, which are more kind of ECM modulating.
So to summarize this part, we find that
there's a network of stress responses activated in the tumor
microenvironment. We think that this is relevant for therapeutic
targeting both of the oxidative stress response in the stroma,
and of the heat shock response in the context of BRCA-mutated cancers.
And we think that this is really a potential avenue to
pursue therapeutically, and we are actually doing that.
There's one more type of stress that I didn't talk about, but I'm happy to
talk about later if anyone's interested, and that is inflammation that we are
also looking into very extensively.
All right, so in the last few minutes of my talk, I'd like to switch
gears a little bit and talk about a different
stress-related
role of cancer-associated fibroblasts, and that is through their
interaction with the immune microenvironment.
So as I mentioned in the beginning of my talk, CAFs
regulate the immune microenvironment through
various different pathways, and we were interested in
understanding whether
specifically CAFs regulate NK cells, so natural killer cells.
NK cells are cells that are supposed to deal with
stressed cells. So they're supposed to eat stressed cells, they're
supposed to eat cancer cells, but this doesn't always happen.
And we were interested in understanding whether CAFs have anything to
do with the fact that NK cells are not very active in some
types of tumors. So what we did was to
isolate and
use an ex vivo model where we combine NK
cells, CAFs from tumors, and cancer cells, in this case, for
tumor and breast cancer, triple negative breast cancer cells.
And what we found was that when you
pre-incubate or expose the NK cells to CAFs
before they meet the cancer cells,
they cannot kill the cancer cells very efficiently.
So these are, again, these pCAFs, these podoplanin positive CAFs, and
compared to normal mammary fibroblasts,
the NK cells are really inhibited by these cells.
How is this mediated? So
we looked at
different receptors on the NK cells.
They have a repertoire of activating and inhibitory
receptors. And what we found was that the expression of two
activating receptors, NKG2D and DNAM1, is
inhibited when they're incubated or when they were
exposed to CAFs compared to no exposure
or compared to normal mammary fibroblasts, which show kind of a
partial phenotype.
Is this through ligand receptor interaction?
So we looked at the ligands for these receptors on the CAFs, and
we found that indeed, some of these ligands are
activated or overexpressed in the CAFs,
as shown here for CD155 and ULBP1.
So then our hypothesis was that, so we have
ligand receptor binding, and thenWhat happens?
So we thought that potentially this could be internalized, the
complex of the ligand receptor, and then the NK cells are left without these
activating receptors. And so to look at this,
we looked at the expression of
the ligands and receptors on the NK cells upon
interaction with the cancer-associated fibroblasts using ImageStream.
So what you can see here is that when we
have the
NK cells here, you see DNAM1 expressed on the cell surface
of the NK cells. But then when we add the fibroblasts
before, when they are exposed to fibroblasts, indeed, this
complex is internalized, and this is quantified here.
But does this really affect the cytotoxicity?
Do these ligand receptor interactions affect the cytotoxicity of the NK
cells? So the answer is yes. We used inhibitory
antibodies in order to block this interaction, and we found that indeed,
when we block this interaction, we can partially rescue the
phenotype.
So what's happening here? How are the CAFs inhibiting the NK
cells? So we thought that maybe the NK cells are eating
the CAFs and then they are exhausted or
cannot, for some reason,
then attack the cancer cells. And so to test
this, we did direct tricultures, where we mixed the
NK cells with the fibroblasts and the cancer cells at the same time,
and we looked at how they kill both cell types.
So you can see this here. I'll play the movie in a second.
And you'll see the fibroblasts in pink, the cancer cells here in green,
and the NK cells are transparent. And what we found is that they
kill the CAFs much faster than they kill the cancer cells.
And this is quantified here, suggesting that it's really
through the phagocytosis of CAFs
that the NK cells cannot then kill the cancer
cells.
So this was all done with
cells isolated from tumors, but we still wanted to see what happens
actually in the mouse, what happens in vivo, because this was all ex vivo.
And so to do this, we used a different cancer
cell line, which
we can orthotopically inject into syngeneic
mice. But this cell line comes in two flavors.
It's called T2A1, and it has
a more metastatic version, which also recruits more stroma,
as you can see here with smooth muscle actin staining.
And so we try to look at how these tumors form
when we inhibit or deplete NK cells in the mice.
And what we found was that when you deplete NK cells
in the parental strain, which is less stromal, indeed, we see much
more stroma now, suggesting that when you don't have NK cells,
you have much more CAFs. And we didn't see this in the more
metastatic line, which has so many CAFs that the NK cells are probably
overwhelmed by them, and this is quantified here.
We also looked directly at CAF accumulation, so this is looking
at collagen, but we also looked at CAFs directly, and we
saw the same phenotype. And finally, we wanted to see that
this is relevant to the human disease, and so we performed
multiplex immunofluorescence staining of tissue
microarray from breast cancer patients.
And we found that expression of nectin-2
on the fibroblasts in
these cancer patients was correlated with poor survival, suggesting that
indeed,
there is an effect in patients.
So to summarize this story, what we think is that the
CAFs serve as decoys for the NK
cells, so they engage the NK cells, and then the NK cells
cannot kill the cancer cells efficiently.
And so to sort of summarize everything I showed you today,
we think that tumor microenvironments, or in the case of
fibroblasts at least, they are rewired to become
protumorigenic by a combination of signals from the mutated
cancer cells as well as from the microenvironment, and that
stress responses are really important in driving these
phenotypic changes.
And finally, I'd like to end by acknowledging the people who
did this work. So these are my wonderful
students. And we have various
collaborators, both at the Weizmann Institute and
internationally. Some of them are here.
Our funding, and I really want to thank you all for
being here. Thanks again, Michaela, for organizing this session.
And thanks to all my friends and colleagues who
built the foundation for all this beautiful work that we could continue
from. And one of them is asking a question now, so thank you.
Beautiful talk. I have a question about the phenotype of these NK
cells.
Is it sustained? Is it reversible?
And have you also looked at metabolites?
Yeah. So
we don't think it's reversible, at least in the
timescales that we looked at it. Will it be reversible eventually in
the mice? They will form new NK cells, but the ones that are already
exhausted, they cannot go back, at least in our hands, to being
active.
Does it have to do with metabolites? We haven't looked.
It's a really good question. So yeah.
Sheila has a question there.
Sorry, I jumped up late. So it's a little bit similar to the other question, but
have you looked at, in your transcriptomics at lipids
and lipid synthesis? Because Leah Lynch has shown a lot of
really nice data that lipid changes really affect
NK cells, and CAFs tend to shift some of their lipid
profiles.
No, we haven't looked at it, and it's a really interesting point
that we should look into. I will say also that we're
now actually following this study, we expanded this
also to gamma delta T cells, which seem to be doing kind of
similar things to the NK cells. So this is a really good point that we'll
look at in that context. Thanks, Sheila.
Hello. Beautiful talk. I was wondering, fibroblasts in
a tumor versus normal self, normal
tissue, are those in the tumor more stressed?
That's why they express more ligands for NK
cells, and what is stressing them?
Yeah, so we definitely think that they're more stressed.
What is stressing them,
and going back to the questions that both Val and Sheila asked, whether it's
metabolites, lipids, we need to look further into
it. But we do think that it's gradients
of metabolic factors,
hypoxia, all these stress responses that I talked about in the beginning that will
be creating these different niches in which
they're more active. So for the NK cells, we actually showed that
there's
differential localization of them in stroma-rich
versus cancer-rich areas. We didn't look within the
microenvironment, if there are different niches within the stroma where we
see different metabolites, but yeah.
I was wondering, I saw in your movie that the killed NK
cells seems to be accumulating in big cells.
Do you, by any chance, have macrophages contaminating your culture?
And I'm asking because, we have unpublished data where we
activate macrophages, and they too will
kill and eat,
the CAFs in our cultures.
So,
we don't think that we have macrophages contaminating them.
We did have that as an issue in the beginning, so we repeated these experiments to
make sure that we don't. But whether this could be happening in
vivo? Probably, yes. So definitely.
Hey, Ruthie. That was great, thank you.
I have a question. It's probably going to ask you more to speculate,
but I wonder if you've looked at the whole profile of various NK
receptors and if there are conditions where you see
switches in receptor activation versus suppression
under various treatment conditions.
One thing I'll throw out there is we see these things change a lot with age,
so be something cool to explore. But I wonder if you've started to look at other
treatment conditions.
So we didn't look at treatment conditions. It's a really good point.
And we didn't look at aging, and there's Sheila's beautiful work on the
NK cells in
aging and the senescent CAFs. So
we haven't looked at them, but different treatment conditions is a
great idea, too.
Cool.
Thank you for all these great ideas.
All right, thanks a lot.
That is not my talk.
Could I get my talk, please?
The other one.
There we go. All right. So, I will continue in
the vein of thinking about the tumor microenvironment,
how cells are responding to stress, and how that may affect
cancer progression.
And so first my disclosures.
So what we are talking about today is how stress may
regulate cancer progression. And of course, this is supported by
work from population studies reviewed in, for
instance, these two papers, where they're showing across multiple types of
cancer that exposure to stress is associated with
poor survival and particularly metastasis.
Conversely, if you can support patients,
they tend to live longer.
There's a lot of challenges for someone like me in following up with
these studies. How do you study stress and cancer and get to the
core of how it's working? How do we define and
measure stress and its effect on individuals?
One of the things I noticed was at some point they were looking at life events.
But, as we all know, different life events may affect us
differently. A divorce may be very stressful for one partner
and rather a relief for the other one.
In addition,
we respond differently
to stressors, some with maladaptation and some with resilience.
These are very hard questions for me to address as a cancer biologist, and
that's why we have this combined session.
So hopefully Jesse will be able to educate me on this.
What we do know is that the
brain is sensing the stress, and the HPA stress circuit is-
Very well characterized. It starts in the hypothalamus that's
activating the pituitary gland, and then the adrenal gland, leading
to cortisol release. Of course, there's also the
sympathetic nervous system, and unfortunately, in this
symposium, we are not really able to address that, but it is there, and it's
affecting cancer, too. The HPA stress circuit
is
well conserved between people and rodents, and that
allowed a former postdoctoral fellow in my lab, Suyun He,
to try to ask, using mice, how does stress affect cancer
progression, and particularly metastasis, and how do
these stress hormones, the glucocorticoids, affect the
tumor immune microenvironment?
She started by combining mouse models of cancer
progression and metastasis with mouse models that we adapted
from the neuroscience field on exposing mice to
stress. So tumor cells were inoculated in a mammary fat
pad. The tumors were allowed to grow and disseminate
spontaneously, and then they were surgically removed.
And then the mice was exposed to daily restraint stress.
Literally, they are putting in Falcon tubes for two hours a day
to stress them. In the end of the experiment, we then
detect metastasis.
As you can see here, what she found was that the corticosterone level, the
glucocorticoids, were increased as we wanted to model,
and there was also a robust metastatic burden increase
about fourfold, but with a lot of variability in how
they responded.
Interestingly, and I'll get back to that at the end of the talk, we noticed that in
the control animals, we had smaller lesions and fewer of them
were proliferating compared to in animals exposed to
restraint stress.
Now, we recognize that a cancer patient is not put in a
Falcon tube two hours a day, so we wanted to try to model
better the kind of stress that we as patients may
experience by using what's known as a chronic unpredictable
mild stress model, where the
animals are randomized to different stresses every day.
So these might be tail pinch, noise, stroboscopic
light, food deprivation, water deprivation, and various
changes to the environment, to the cage environment.
This is a very involved protocol, and to sort of
combine that with the dissemination, what Suyun did in
collaboration with Evdokia and Shanu from my collaborator, Linda
Vanal's lab, was to now make it a little bit simpler and
inject the cancer cells directly intravenously so they disseminated to the lung,
and then expose them to the protocol.
As you can see here, also with this protocol, there's an increase in corticosterone
level. It's less. It's supposed to be a milder protocol, and the
metastatic burden is increasing.
So how does this work?
What we found just using tumor-free animals was that the
lung tissue was profoundly changed after three weeks of
exposure to these stressors.
So there was not just one thing but a global change.
There was an accumulation of extracellular matrix, fibronectin.
There was a reduction in an infiltration of T cells,
and then there was an expansion of the infiltration of neutrophils,
whether we measured by immunohistochemistry or by flow cytometry.
So we really got intrigued about the infiltration of
neutrophils.
Neutrophils are a very intriguing cell type.
It's actually our most abundant white blood cell,
yet it's been pretty understudied, particularly in cancer,
until recently. I think one of the reasons it's not been studied
as much is they're short-lived, 12 hours to five days,
depending on where it is in the tissue or in the blood.
So in culture, they are pretty hard to--
So not easy to work with.
Since they have such a big turnover, we produce and
then also dispose of a staggering 100
billion neutrophils every day. Think of that as two
neutrophils for every dollar on the NIH budget that is being
produced every day, and we can only hope that the
NIH budget will not be neutropenic.
Also, for the
neutrophils, it's now known that they have both pro and anti-tumor
functions, just like many other immune cells in the
microenvironment. My lab have mostly focused on the pro-tumor function,
but there are very strong data supporting that they can also directly kill
cancer cells.
They have this very unique type of cell death called neutrophil extracellular
trap formation, NET or NET formation, and by scanning
electron microscopy, it looks like this.
These are strings of extracellular DNA that's being expelled
into the extracellular room, and they are decorated with
various enzymes and proteins and, of course, nucleic acids from the
neutrophil.
These traps were discovered or first reported on in
2004, and since then, there's been quite a lot of
publications on their function in cancer.
We now know that they are induced not just by pathogens.
They are induced during inflammation and on, of course,
infection. And some of the factors that induce them are bacterial
components but also chemokines or extracellular
vesicles. And so in a tumor microenvironment, these factors can
come, for instance, from cancer cells directly.
In human cancers, there's been correlation between NETs and
tumor stage and poor prognosis across a variety of different cancers,
and there's also now clear evidence that they may confer
resistance to chemotherapy.Mechanistically,
what they do in the context of metastasis is that they can induce
migration and invasion of cancer cells, and they can help the cancer cells
extravasate at the secondary site.
And they also really support this metastatic niche formation,
where they alter the microenvironment where the cancer cell will
later take seed.
Going back to our cancer study, what we saw was that when we looked in the
mice that had been stressed, looked at neutrophils taken from these
mice, and kept just a few hours ex vivo, you can
see that they were forming a staggering extra number of neutrophils.
Each of these arrows represent a neutrophil forming NETs, as
quantified here.
We found that this was directly mediated by glucocorticoids acting on the
glucocorticoid receptor in neutrophils.
If we use conditional knockout animals lacking the receptor
neutrophils, there was no increase in the NET formation in these
neutrophils.
There was also no increase in metastasis when you
used animals that did not have the glucocorticoid receptor in the neutrophils,
really suggesting that the neutrophils were key, and their response to the
glucocorticoids were key in
promoting of metastasis. But was it the NETs?
And so to test this, what Suyun did was that she, again, did
the spontaneous dissemination model, allowing tumor cells to
grow and disseminate, remove the primary tumors, exposed the
mice to restraint stress, or did that in the context of DNase,
a enzyme that can chop off the extracellular DNA.
If she did that, you can see that DNase worked well.
It reduced DNase in the plasma,
and it reduced significantly the metastasis
in the lungs of the stressed animals, almost back to background
level. We think it's not one thing that the NETs are doing, but
really a global change in the microenvironment.
And so what you can see here is that when we stress and combine with
DNase, extracellular matrix accumulation is also reduced,
although not all the way to background levels.
Now, this is all mice, and of course, we want to think about what can
cause elevated glucocorticoid levels in patients.
And there's a variety of different things that might cause that.
One, of course, is when you get diagnosed with cancer.
It is an exceptionally stressful event.
You may wonder what's going to happen to you.
When you're exposed to a treatment, that is stressful. Will it respond?
And a lot of treatments are stressful in themself.
And of course, there can be financial concerns of what is the
cancer going to mean for your family.
In addition, we are using glucocorticoids in the clinic.
They're
often used with anesthesia, they're used with chemotherapy, and
they're used in anti-inflammatory treatment after surgery.
So a lot of the things that the cancer patient may be treated with may involve
synthetic glucocorticoid exposure.
Interestingly, it may even be that having a tumor by itself
is a stressor. This is a study where they looked in plasma
from patients with pancreatic cancer, and they noted that
there is almost a doubling in the circulating glucocorticoid levels
in these cancer patients.
So we wanted to see what does glucocorticoids do
by themself. And we wanted now to focus really here on the
secondary side, where
the cancer cells are arriving. We know that for many cases,
cancer may arrive to a secondary tissue, and then in the
context of, for instance, breast cancer, they can be dormant for years or
decades before they are awakened.
I think it's not just breast cancer where this is relevant for.
This is data from my former colleague, Doc Fearon at Cold Spring
Harbor, who had looked in autopsies from pancreatic cancer
patients, one of the most aggressive types of cancer.
Yet,
some patients do live with this cancer, and when they
autopsies, you can see here that there are single disseminated
cancer cells in the liver. They are positive for mutant
p53, but negative for proliferation markers.
So I think as we get better and better to treat aggressive cancers
such as pancreatic cancer with a KRES inhibitor or with
vaccines, this may actually be more important than we are
thinking about now.
So Doc Fearon had developed a model of disseminated
latent pancreatic cancer, and we further, and by we, I
mean my former graduate student, Xiao Han,
adjusted this model, refined it. So what she's doing is
she's taking pancreatic cancer cells expressing GFP or
luciferase. So they're sort of model antigens that also
allow us to follow them.
Like Suyun had done, she is allowing these tumors to grow
for three weeks, so an immune response can be raised against these cells.
They're surgically removed.
We had done them subcutaneously to get the immune response and also to avoid that
there's any dissemination to the liver from this site.
And then you follow by luciferase.
You can see here that in naive animals that's injected with these
cancer cells into the spleen, into the hepatic circulation, they're
growing rapidly. So that is how we are normally doing
experimental metastasis, and I think it's maybe
underestimating how much the immune response is playing a role in
regulating metastasis. Because in these other mice, you can see there
is no detectable metastasis by bioluminescence.
But when you look closely in the microscope, and again, taking
advantage of these cells expressing mutant p53, so we can detect
them, you can see here that by day 15, when these
naive animals have 20% of their livers occupied
by cancer-In the immunized mice, you cannot
detect metastasis unless you stain for p53 and find
these individual cancer cells localized in
the
liver.
These cells, when you look closely, are almost all
95% negative for Ki-67,
5% are cycling. Of course, this is p53,
so we wanted to be really sure that these were cancer cells, and
adapted a reporter that was developed in
Ana Correia's lab. Ana Correia is one of our new ACR
trailblazers, and she is really fantastic, and shared this construct
with us. So now we can look in the liver.
This is seven days after injection of the cells into the
hepatic circulation. You have the red
disseminated tumor cells. You can see a single cell here and a single cell
up here. This one is GFP positive, and it is
around E-cadherin positive epithelial cells in the liver,
with this one is not positive for GFP, so we think it's
cycling. And you can see there's a lot of
E-cadherin negative cells around it, possibly immune cells.
If we quantify this, you can see again, like with
p53, it's 95% of the cells that are not
cycling, that are quiescent and dormant.
So what happens if we expose these animals to glucocorticoids?
We now try to model what's happening in pancreatic cancer
patients by
injecting these cells into the hepatic circulation and then
exposing the mice to glucocorticoids in the drinking water,
increasing the levels of circulating glucocorticoids with about
twofold.
If we do that, there is profound changes in the liver
microenvironment.
Here, just in percentages, you can see an expansion of the neutrophils, really
dramatic, and a retraction of the CD8 and CD4 T
cells, and these changes were significant.
This is after one week. It's robust even after six weeks of continuous
treatment. Here, after four weeks, I'm just showing you the immunohistochemistry
where you really get a sense of how few T cells are present with the
corticosterone, and how many myeloperoxidase positive
neutrophils. These neutrophils are forming NET, as quantified
here, so there's a really profound increase in NET formation also with
glucocorticoid treatment directly.
So, of course, we had hoped that there would, or at least expected
that there would be metastasis, but as you can see here, these elevated
levels of glucocorticoids and these profound
changes in T cell and neutrophil infiltration did
not change the outcome of the mice.
It did not have metastasis in all the ones we've looked at so far.
What they did have when we look closely in the microscope was that there was a
change in the proliferation status.
So now with corticosterone, you're starting to really see a lot more
of the cycling cells that are Ki-67 positive, almost
35, 40%.
When you look at whether or not they're single cells versus doublets, again, we are
actually seeing double cells in the liver, but no more than
that.
So what is preventing these glucocorticoid-induced proliferating cells
from now forming metastasis?
I think it will not surprise many people that T cells.
We had built this to train the mice to respond to the
antigen. So what we did next was to do T cell depletion in the
context of glucocorticoid treatment.
Again, with a vehicle, all mice stay
tumor-free or metastasis-free. They have just these dormant cells, but they do not
develop metastasis. Glucocorticoids, no metastasis.
Vehicle,
but the T cell depletion by itself, we start to see a few smaller
metastasis, and when we combine glucocorticoid treatment
with T cell depletion, we get a lot of
metastasis, in almost all mice. And here's a
quantification. About a third of the mice get metastasis just with
T cell depletion, but they are few and smaller, and almost
all mice with the combined treatment.
So to summarize this, we have these quiescent cancer cells
sitting in the tissue, and there's a small percentage of them
that are cycling in our models, about 5%.
They could form tumors, but they are not.
And I think they are really being kept in check by the
adaptive immune response in the tissue.
We can increase the number of cells that are
going from quiescent to proliferating, for instance, by having more
neutrophils and NET in the tissue, and one of the ways that can
happen is through glucocorticoids.
So there's this balance of factors that are stimulating
proliferation, but there's also a break of a
cytotoxic immune cells that are keeping these cells from growing out.
I wanted to discuss this finding in the context of other
studies in this field. There was a really nice paper from Julia Goethe's
lab that just came out about a month ago.
And what she was reporting was indeed that glucocorticoids
were important for the clearance of disseminated tumor cells,
not dormant, but disseminated cells.
And
what she was looking at was the specific effects of
glucocorticoids on cancer cells on how it was regulating the
expression of FAS and thereby facilitating a better
clearance by T cells.Now,
our data as well as her data shows that glucocorticoids
promote metastasis.
And she proposed that you could use mifepristone to block
glucocorticoids together with checkpoint blockade.
But the devil is in the detail here.
This is a study from Momo Bentia's lab, and what he
found was that glucocorticoids can inhibit metastasis in the
context of estrogen receptor-positive breast cancer
models. And here, he's proposing that is because it's
interfering with estrogen receptor function.
So I think we really need to think about how is glucocorticoids acting
in different cells, in different context, and
clearly, we can't treat the different types of cancer the same way.
So to summarize,
what I shown you is that the chronic stress and the glucocorticoids is
shifting the balance between immune surveillance and metastatic
outgrowth, and they are acting on host cells.
But we are finding, like others, that there are also direct effects on cancer
cells. So it's very complex. Multiple cells are responding.
The metastatic outgrowth can be controlled by the loss of the
brake, adaptive immune cells, as well as some
accelerant. In this context of these studies, it's a neutrophil and NETs, but
I'm sure there are other cells that can do these other factors that can trick this
proliferation. I think it's really important, though, to think about that there are
two steps.
The other implication is that the systemic microenvironment,
here, the
chronic stress or elevated glucocorticoid levels, are
regulating whether or not a disseminated dormant tumor cells is
able to form a metastasis. So it
decides the switch of whether it's promoting or suppressing local
microenvironment. And to me, that's an opportunity.
It shows us that the microenvironment is plastic.
Maybe stress can push it one way, but hopefully, we will have a way
of preventing that through secondary prevention, keeping the
cells from growing out,
starting being clever about what's going on in the microenvironment.
I want to end by thanking again the people that did the work.
Sooyoung Heo, that started all of this when she was a postdoc in my
lab, and she is now going to present shortly in a mini
symposium data from her own lab on the effect of stress in
colorectal cancer. And it's such a joy to watch her establish
her program. Xiao Han did all of these
models on pancreatic cancer when she was a graduate student in my lab, and
Yulu is now
taking this to the finish line, hopefully, and expanding,
trying to understand what's really going on.
I want to thank also my collaborators, and I want to thank you for your attention,
and I'll be happy to take any questions. Thank you very much.
Hello.
Very nice work. So what the
molecules can switch
the stress on tumor growth? For
example, some
people get stress for, some people maybe feel
happy.
So what kind of molecules is a switch?
So in what kind of threshold they can
be stressed, so the tumor-
I think, yeah
... can grow, yeah.
I think that's a very good question, and I must admit, I don't have
a good answer for you. As you could see in our data, we are
finding that some animals do not respond with more metastasis.
So something's different with them.
We know that the time of day matters a lot for the glucocorticoid
response. It's regulated by the circadian
cycle, and I have a suspicion that when the stress happens
may matter, too, as one component.
Of course, we have not really explored at all the sympathetic
response to stress, and so, there's literature on
that, too. How do these factors interact?
I don't have an answer for you, but I think it's really important to try to get
to that. I will just say that glucocorticoids
themselves acting on the receptor in different cells seem to be
key.
So another question, because you and you do the stress under the
mouse, under the tumor growth. How can we
apply the data from the mouse to human being?
Because it's very hard to do the stress experiment
on human being.
It is very hard, and we probably don't want to if we can avoid it.
This is where we need to collaborate with population scientists and
people that are doing molecular epidemiology and really can start to
detect some of the biomarkers, which are
biological markers of the stress response.
I'm thinking that one opportunity would be to look at the neutrophils themselves.
You can take them by simple blood samples, and we do see change in
expression in the neutrophils. So that's a potential
marker that we are trying to explore.
How can you inhibit it is your other question.
I think that's too early to do.
As I pointed out, when you inhibit, like with mifepristone, which is an
inhibitor,
it may work under the conditions that we showed with the triple-negative
tumors or with the pancreatic cancer tumor.
But the data from Momo's lab really gives me pause
that we maybe don't want to do that without understanding better what you're
regulating.
So I want to ask your perspective.
I think since we have-
In Asian country
They don't care the patients you get cancer.
But here, doesn't matter. You can tell them what your
perspective is, whether cause stress or without
stress. Thank you.
I think it depends on the person. Personally, if I had a
cancer diagnosis, I would like to know, but I think that's personal.
Sandra?
Hi. That was great, Mick. Thank you.
I
like your ideas about plasticity of micro and macro environment.
I'm wondering if you know a bit about the heterogeneity of the tumor
cells themselves and the state in which
they're poised to respond in different ways.
It may be that the pro and anti-tumor effects may
be converging on the tumor cells themselves and not
just expression of glucocorticoid receptor, but
an epithelial cell versus a mesenchymal-like cell expressing the
receptor are going to behave differently.
I think that's a great question. I don't have a good answer for you.
I know that Judy was looking a bit on
how the cancer cells
responding to glucocorticoid was affecting the immune response around them.
And we noted, as I pointed out, that there is a different
response around the cells that are cycling, suggesting that
the cycling state itself may be critical.
We've seen this on some of the old movies I made with Doc, too,
that you see T cells come in when there are
cycling cancer cells. They also have this
elongated shape. Is it EMT? I don't know, but this is one
of the things we really want to do with spatial omics technologies.
Interesting. Thanks.
Great talk. In connection with the first talk, I
wonder if you have checked the effects of chronic stress on fibroblasts
in your models.
On which one?
In the chronic stress models.
On?
On fibroblasts.
No, we have not. We
should.
Hi, Michela. Such a nice work. So I'm trying to get, in
the
model when you immunize, you have the DTC.
If you don't immunize, you actually have disseminated growth,
right?
Yeah.
So, there's no stress. Well, you didn't give stress to the
animal at that moment in that experiment, right?
Yeah.
So does that suggest that the presence or absence of
T cell might
actually impact, I don't know, the stress
response in this wild-type condition?
I think the T cells are very much affected by the stress
response. When we don't immunize, when we don't or
condition the mouse,
there's no time for the T cell response to adapt.
You could see that these metastases grow rapidly.
We've tried to lower the number, but they still grow, and I think it's because you
just don't have time to establish an immune-suppressive.
There's an immune-suppressive environment established before the T cells can
respond.
Yeah.
I think this is important to think about because, in a patient, there will have
been time.
Of course, cancer cells have many different ways that they can escape, but I think
it, to me, questions how we're doing experimental metastasis
assays.
Thank you.
Great presentation.
I am a population scientist, and my question is
mainly on
data we could use at a population level to
capture chronic stress. I don't know how cortisol level is a
good measure to address chronic stress.
I see sometimes people using allostatic load-
Yeah
... to capture that. Could you please comment on what can we
use whenever we're trying to address the question using
population-level data?
This is why I want to speak with you guys, because I don't
know. I think corticosteroids by themself is going to be hard.
They circle through the day, and you need to
know what the cycle of a person is. Even on the mice, we see huge
fluctuations. So I don't think they by themself are sufficient.
The allosteric load is really intriguing to me,
so I have not explored it in full yet, but it's one of the
directions we would like to take.
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you.
And so with that, I'd like to introduce the next speaker, Jesse.
May I just?
Oh.
Hi. Shelley Chu Roger at Oregon Health & Science University.
As a population scientist who studies stress and cancer, there's lots of ways that
you can evaluate it. The most common is self-reported
distress, so things like depression, anxiety,
PTSD symptoms, social isolation.
There's a lot of coping that happens, so sometimes that doesn't capture.
There's several studies that have been published by Laura Kubzansky at Harvard and
Sue Hankinson at UMass Amherst on metabolic scores of
distress, blood-based metabolic scores of distress.
And there are ways to measure stress hormone.
There's new assays to measure urinary norepinephrine
metabolites that have just come out that can be
used. So-
Thank you for that
... there's lots of ways.
Thanks for that, and I can add that maybe one of the strongest
epidemiological connection with cancer is not just with stress,
but with anxiety and depression, and of course, that link is very
important. Thank you. And now Jesse.
Good afternoon, everyone.
So, this is going to be a sharp pivot to
away from cancer biology, tumor microenvironments, and more to population sciences.
But I want to thank everyone for joining, and I want to also thank the
ASPO or ACR
planning committee, as well as Michela and Ruth for allowing
me to join you in this presentation.On
the stage. I have no conflicts of interest.
I sped through that, but I promise I have none.
The main points I'm going to get across today, I'm going to present to you right
now, are that specific social stressors may be associated with
epigenetic age acceleration,
and that accelerated epigenetic age trajectories might
vary by specific social stressors.
And so I'm going to add to Dr. Tu Rogers'
comments about how to measure stress, and I'm going to challenge us to consider
whether epigenetic age acceleration could be an
arguably downstream measure of stress response.
So, with a history spanning decades, studies have generally shown that
exposure to greater social stressors is associated with
worse survival outcomes from breast cancer and other cancers as well.
Arguably, the most common social stressor investigated is some measure of
socioeconomics at the individual or contextual level, such as
neighborhoods.
This has been shown whether measuring neighborhood socioeconomic factors
from such measures as percent of the population considered working class within a
block group, which is what I'm showing you here of this early, nearly 40-year-old
study at this point,
or more recent studies that utilize composite measures of contextual
socioeconomics, such as the Area Deprivation Index.
Some studies have demonstrated attenuation of associations with adjustment
for individual-level socioeconomic measures, which is what I'm showing you here.
And this attenuation is notable because it forces us to consider whether
contextual measures of socioeconomics are
compositional or truly contextual, and whether individual
socioeconomic adjustment is necessary to control for the
forces that influence where individuals live, such as selective
residential mobility. So we have numerous reviews and
frameworks to help us understand how characteristics of social stressors might
eventually adversely impact breast cancer outcomes and other
cancers as well. Epidemiologically, cancer is considered a
rare outcome, which has led many investigators to use
population-based, central state-based cancer registries,
such as some of those that I presented in the previous slide.
The majority of these registry-based studies of those diagnosed with
cancer have focused on publicly available Census
Bureau-based measures of social stressors, such as
socioeconomic composition, racial ethnic segregation, and
discriminatory mortgage lending practices and other forms of structural racism.
Despite large variation in these concepts and measures, several mechanistically
converge in hypothesizing that psychosocial stress might be involved in pathways
from neighborhoods to breast cancer survival, which is a main point of this
article I'm showing you right here by Cineas and colleagues.
This review also suggests that DNA methylation may be
an important link between social stressors and cancer biology.
The review by Muravik and colleagues was more physiologic and
psychoneurologically oriented than the Cineas review, and they
summarized the evidence for neuroendocrine pathways, including the
hypothalamic pituitary adrenal cortical access,
which we heard from
before in relation to the hallmarks of cancer by Hanahan and
Weinberg, with attention to key points in the hallmarks of cancer, including
cancer growth and metastases, which again, we just heard about.
Around the same time, Steve Cole of UCLA proposed that a constellation of
inflammatory and immune genes might be consistently and differentially
expressed when comparing populations experiencing various stressors,
including social stressors, a process
he termed conserved transcriptional response to adversity.
A recent meta-analysis by Welms et al., which is, I believe still a
preprint, reviewed 140 studies to summarize associations between
social stressors and three generations of epigenetic aging clocks.
Epigenetic aging clocks refer to DNA methylation-based measures of biologic
aging, typically assessed and validated from peripheral blood samples.
The strongest associations between socioeconomic stressors were reserved for
third-generation epigenetic clocks, sometimes referred to as epigenetic
speedometers,
developed to predict the pace of aging.
Meta-analytic Pearson correlation coefficients between adult
socioeconomic status and DunedinPACE epigenetic age
acceleration was negative 0.18, meaning that as socioeconomic
status increases,
age decelerates, biologic age decelerates.
A study by Opsasnick and colleagues took an EWAS approach to test relationships
between self-reported stressors across various domains, including
acute trauma, stressful life events, financial stress, relationship
stress, lifetime discrimination, childhood adversity, and neighborhood stress,
which I'm going to note, especially because I'm going to show some results later
about neighborhood factors. Their measure included perceptions of
graffiti, litter, and vacant buildings.
Methylation of nine CpGs previously associated with mental health, inflammation,
and smoking were associated with
the summative measure of stress from those
seven domains that I mentioned. Domain-specific results mirrored
those of the general stress measure.
This 2019 review and meta-analysis by O'Brien summarized dozens of health
studies where neighborhood disorder was an exposure.
The physical dimension of neighborhood disorder is also called disinvestment, is a
measure of infrastructure deterioration and disrepair,
and is indicated by characteristics such as garbage, graffiti, abandoned buildings,
some of those same measures from the Opsasnick
study that I just mentioned. They conclude that the most likely pathway for an
association between neighborhood disorder and health outcomes is through
psychosocial
stress.Almost
getting to interesting data. This will be the last slide on motivation.
The study by Poganec and colleagues tested transient changes
in epigenetic age acceleration longitudinally with repeated measures
before and after such stressful life events,
including major surgery and severe COVID-19 infection among
individuals. With epigenetic age measures separated only by
days or weeks, the general trend was a rapid increase in
aging, which reversed within the recovery periods of surgery
and after COVID-19 infection recovery.
The last study I will show is by Eugenia South and colleagues.
It's one of the few randomized trials in humans that tested the effect of a
neighborhood social stressor on perceived stress, Kessler K6 distress.
Vacant lots in Philadelphia were randomized to receive remediation or not receive
remediation. The remediation intervention involved
trash pickup and intensive landscaping.
Those that
lived around the remediated lots reported lower levels of distress.
Ah, and the last thing I want to mention is that this measure of
neighborhood disorder or disinvestment is something that's readily modifiable.
So when thinking about translation and what could we do with this evidence
of social factors impacting stressors, this is a
measure that is readily intervened upon already.
So getting to the research question.
So we were interested in which social stressors were associated with this
third-generation epigenetic aging acceleration or epigenetic clock
that was measured approximately two years following a breast cancer diagnosis
among African American or Black women diagnosed with breast cancer and
residing in New Jersey.
So just as a real quick primer on what the Dunand and Pace epigenetic age
acceleration measure is, I may refer to it as PACE, is
essentially a value greater than one because it's standardized to
chronologic age, indicates accelerated aging,
and then values less than one
represent decelerated aging. For an example, a 54-year-old with a value
of 0.66 in chronologic
years would have a biologic value of 36 years,
whereas a 33% increase in
epigenetic aging for that 54-year-old would have them placed at
a biologic age of 72.
So data were from 312 participants of the Women's Circle of Health
follow-up study, which as I mentioned,
was
comprised of African American or Black women self-identifying that way
between the ages of 20 and 74 years.
And we limited this analysis to those diagnosed with invasive Stage
1 through 4 breast cancer. The study was led by Elisa Bandera,
Katal Dimasi, and Chicheng Hong. And the work that I'm presenting today was
primarily in collaboration with Adenios, Kelly Archer, Prashant Singh, and
Song Yao.
We generated, with help of
Kelly Archer, Dunand and Pace epigenetic age acceleration measures from peripheral
blood samples, as you can see here, that were drawn about two years post-diagnosis.
The Epic 850K array was used on samples randomized to row, chip, and
plate with respect to exposure measures.
Bioinformatics led by Kelly included white blood
cell proportion corrections, batch correction, and other analyses
mainly using the bio methyl clock bioconductor package.
So to give you an idea of the social stressors that we have, I'm going to break
this up by self-report.
And
we had educational attainment and household income to poverty ratio, which is
essentially income as a function of the federal poverty level, which accounts for
household size, and this was by year because the poverty level
increases in dollar amount every year.
In parentheses for each of these, I'm showing what is our
least
stressed group within this
measure versus the most stressed group.
So obviously, high education or high income would be considered the
least stressed group.
We had nativity, marital status, health insurance, perceived
physical and social neighborhood disorders.
So this is individuals' perceptions of the
disrepair or deterioration of their neighborhood for
physical aspect. For the social aspect, it was essentially things like
are there individuals who loiter in this area,
indications of breakdown of social relationships.
And we also have perceived neighborhood social cohesion, which is
more of a measure of neighborliness, neighbors share values
with one another. It's an indicator of and measure of social capital.
For our objective measures, these were through linked from administrative data
sets and other publicly available data
that were linked through address at diagnosis.
We had socioeconomic composition, which we measured by the Yost index at
the census tract level. Residential segregation, which was
African American isolation and dissimilarity indices we used too.
And then built environment disinvestment, engagement, and sidewalk presence, which
we measured from Google Street View virtual audits across the study area.
So what I first want to show are some of the basic descriptive
characteristics of the 312 participants with Dunand and Pace values.
You can see that the average of the sample was representative of
accelerated aging, 1.3.
Again, these were two years approximately post-diagnosis, so hopefully,
most of these participants should be post-treatment as well.
About a third were high school education or less, which indicates slightly
higher educational attainment compared to the US.
Jumping down to the Yost index, which was the census tract level measure of
socioeconomic composition. This was nationally ranked one through 100,
100 being the
lowest poverty, most educated, you can think wealthiest neighborhoods,
and one being the least. And so the sample was dead smack
in the middle, nationally benchmarked.And then for our measure of built environment
disinvestment,
this essentially follows a standard normal distribution mean zero
across the sample. And so 0.6 indicates that
participants lived in slightly elevated,
more disinvested neighborhoods.
In terms of other covariates that were not our social stressors, body
mass index was higher than average.
About 17% were current tobacco smokers.
And the stage distribution, according to AJCC, about nearly
90% were Stage 1 and 2, which is, those of you who
are involved in breast cancer epidemiology, this is definitely shifted more towards
Stage 1 and 2 kind of enrichment or over-representation
compared to the US. Okay. Busy slide, but
what I want to draw your attention to is the first column.
That's the DunedinPACE epigenetic age acceleration values,
going down. And what I'm showing you here are
those covariates in the correlation matrix, those
covariates that had a Pearson correlation with PACE,
that the P value was 0.1 or less.
The social stressors are highlighted here,
and then the non-social stressors are following.
The
top seven absolute value Pearson correlation coefficients
were income-to-poverty
ratio,
perceived physical disorder, neighborhood disinvestment, neighborhood
socioeconomic composition,
BMI, stage at diagnosis, and then chemotherapy receipt.
All of these
relationships in the first column really kind of followed our hypothesized
direction of association. For example, income
increases,
epigenetic age acceleration decreases or decelerates,
except for the asterisk born outside the US.
We would've expected that those that were born outside the US,
being in a group that experiences more social stressors, more discrimination,
would've had greater epigenetic age acceleration compared to
those born in the US, but that was not the case.
So just, I think this is interesting to look at our
minimum value of DunedinPACE, so the most decelerated
aging biologically, compared to the highest value, so the most
accelerated aging. And just compare some
of the, as I mentioned, the seven
factors that had the highest correlation univariately with PACE, and just look
at what those individuals had. So,
the individual in the sample that had the most decelerated aging,
their age was 49 years chronologically, but biologically that's 42.
Chronologically, the most accelerated, age 65, which puts them
biologically to 112.
Stage at diagnosis was somewhat comparable, but that was kind of enriched in our
sample. Stage 1 for decelerated, Stage 2 for accelerated.
Chemotherapy receipt, no for the individual that had deceleration, yes
for acceleration. Body mass index was actually, both of them were
below average for the sample and the US,
about the same. And this is where things get a little interesting.
Income-to-poverty ratio was substantially different.
400% meeting higher income for the decelerated individual
and near the poverty level for the person with accelerated aging.
For the Yoast index, again, 100 is the wealthiest, least poverty
neighborhoods in the whole of US. 86,
so near the highest for decelerated.
Four, so some of the poorest neighborhoods in the US,
for the accelerated. And then perceived physical disorder as
well as objective neighborhood disinvestment, again, huge differences in the
direction we'd expect.
So including in a model, considering in a model,
all 15 of those covariates that had a Pearson correlation P value of less than
0.1, what we found essentially is that, so there was an
association in the direction we'd expect between modeled
DunedinPACE and income. The association between
disinvestment
and PACE was not quite statistically significant.
But that was mainly due to neighborhood socioeconomic
composition, which confounded it by about 33%, even though
neighborhood SES itself, as you can see from the confidence intervals, was not
statistically significant. But we included it in the model anyways.
And then BMI, tobacco use, and stage were also statistically
significant. As you can see, tobacco use
arguably had the largest effect on epigenetic age acceleration.
Okay, research question two is, as you saw previously, we
also had repeated samples of epigenetic age acceleration from an additional blood
draw that was about one and a half years after the first draw, which puts it at
three and a half years post-diagnosis, as you can see from this
timeline. And so the question that we want to know is, are the
trajectories of epigenetic age acceleration,
do they differ based on the
levels of those seven social stressors that we found to be associated with
PACE at the first blood draw?
And so this is just a spaghetti plot, looking at those 38 individuals that had
repeated samples. As you can see, it is quite variable.
We have arguably an outlier, but an individual that
had, assuming they're 54 years old, which is our
average in the sample,
over the course of less than a year,
essentially, so a year of chronologic age, and then they
gained, or you can say kind of decelerated,
became about
15 years younger biologically.
Perhaps an outlier, but we still had individuals that were maybe more in the realm
of 7 to 10 years.
But then also in the opposite direction, within a year, individuals gaining,
perhaps in the order of 5 to 10 years
biologically.However, overall, there was a
slight decrease
or deceleration in age
comparing the means, and this was shown to be statistically significant
through the paired t-test.
So what we're showing here essentially is
getting to the question of whether there is a difference in the association
between these social factors. Again, the seven that were associated with Dunant and
Pace in the first sample. Is there a
difference in the association
between the second sample and the first, testing that with an interaction?
And statistically, we find evidence that there is for income, body mass index, and
stage. But if you really look at all the associations, they follow the same
trend. And that trend is that when looking at
these social factors or social stressors in Pace at time two, there's
an attenuation of the effect. It moved towards null.
And so this may suggest some sort of potential time lag effect
perhaps.
So limitations of this work.
We have small sample sizes, and all of our studies are limited to or the data that
I'm showing you, New Jersey and Black women
diagnosed with breast cancer.
And
these findings, we don't know if they could be generalizable to other populations.
Future studies should hopefully replicate these in other cancer sites.
We have mostly time-invariant exposures.
I didn't go into it much, but we did have
the availability of our objective social stressors were measured
annually. But we only had two measures, as you know, for Dunant and
Pace, epigenetic age acceleration.
And so larger sample sizes with more repeated measures, four or
more, would be fantastic for getting a better sense of what the trajectories in
age acceleration could be as a function of social
stressors.
And lastly,
there are many potential confounding factors that may be at play when looking
at associations between social stressors
and
epigenetic age acceleration. Discrimination is one that comes to mind that we
didn't have measures of or good measures of besides racial ethnic
segregation, but that's kind of a loose measure of discrimination at
the institutional level, and we certainly didn't have any measures of
interpersonal discrimination
or other social network factors besides social cohesion.
So in conclusion, income, neighborhood socioeconomic composition, and
disinvestment are social stressors with associations
with accelerated epigenetic aging.
The trends indicate, as I mentioned, that these three social factors are more
strongly associated with epigenetic aging within a two-year time
frame or two-year lag compared to associations
at a three-and-a-half year time lag.
With that, I'd like to thank my collaborators that made this work
possible including the large team of undergraduate
students that did all the neighborhood disinvestment engagement and sidewalk
walkability auditing.
With that, happy to take any questions and thank you for your attention.
Please.
Hi. Great talk. Thank you. My name is Charlie Roscoe.
I'm from Oregon Health & Science University Knight Cancer Institute.
Yeah, I was thinking about the
difference that you see in round one and round two,
and do you think the diagnosis itself
is linked to accelerated aging in the first round, so those
neighborhood stresses are not going to show up as predominant?
Did you see higher accelerated aging in that first round
closer to the diagnosis?
Absolutely, yeah. I mean, so the data that I showed of the mean
epigenetic age acceleration measure was
1.3. So accelerated aging, and
the biologic age acceleration
decreased between blood draw one and blood draw
two.
So yeah, whether that is
due to treatment. Two years post-diagnosis, again, most women should
be done being treated for their breast cancer.
And I should also mention that we did corrections for
the fact that those that made it to blood draw one
were different systematically than those who were diagnosed, essentially
those with distant stage were underrepresented.
So we corrected for that. So thinking about
biases in the data, we hopefully corrected for some of those things.
But
yeah, there still could be residual
deceleration of age due to other factors over time, for sure.
Yeah, I'm not really thinking about treatment effects as much as like they've just
gone through major stress. So this is like
the age acceleration, right? So
those who have survived would, I guess, in
round one, that diagnosis, treatment, overall
experience. But that is going to make it look
like the neighborhood is having less impact because there's been a major
traumatic event that just happened, if that's a stressor, right?
And that can increase your age acceleration.
Yeah. So the diagnosis
itself, you're saying still weighing on women two years post-diagnosis?
I would assume so-
Yeah
... in a kind of clump, yeah.
Certainly. Yeah, over time as more clear tests, if
there's repeated scans for follow-up. Yeah.
Totally, that could make sense.
You didn't show this, but did you look
when you
saw
the smoke inn, for instancetakes up so much of the
effect if you throw it all in the same model.
Did you look at smokers versus non-smokers?
And it would be interesting to see in kind of
the perfect patient who hasn't smoked and dah, dah, dah,
if the neighborhood factors are stronger in those people
or-
Yeah
... yeah. Did you look into that?
We did not go down the road of interaction testing with some of these covariates.
Part of it, again, it's a small sample, right?
So when talking about how we tease these things apart, we need large
samples. And to do Epic 850K
array
on thousands in order to do interaction testing,
yeah, that gets challenging for sure. But yeah, it's something we can look to do.
With the 312, I think we can definitely look at some interactions for sure.
It's a good suggestion. Thank you.
Thank you.
So hi.
Really nice work, Jesse. I'm Scarlett Gomez from UCSF.
I was curious, maybe in your larger sample, I saw that you
considered the health behaviors as well as BMI and
treatment as covariates, but at least for the health behaviors, do
you feel that they could operate as part on the
pathway from these social stressors to
accelerated aging?
I do. Yeah, absolutely, right? And so it's always a
challenge of
what we consider mediators, what we control for to look at
or to investigate mediation formally. Yeah.
And so I think it's very possible that smoking,
and perhaps BMI, could be mediators in some of these
associations that we're seeing. To be honest, though, Scarlett, I think
when model building, there was very little change in some of
these associations when pulling smoking out
and then looking at how that impacts the yoast disinvestment
association. It didn't change much.
What changed the most, as I show on the slide here, is chemotherapy.
And I left chemotherapy out here because I thought that could be a mediator.
But yeah, chemotherapy was the biggest driver, actually, of changing the
social stressor relationships.
That's interesting.
Thanks for the question.
So I wanted to ask you, as the cancer biologist,
now that I've learned how to measure,
how do you think these different measurements are
biologically affecting the cancer biology, and how do you think
I should incorporate
the insights you're gaining? Do you have any-- I know that's a tough
question, but
what are your thoughts as a young investigator in this field?
Yeah, I
happened upon the epigenetic aging clocks because I feel like they are
capturing a broad kind of swath of the
environment, right? And by environment, I mean writ large, the things that
we are exposed to outside of our bodies.
And so that's why I happened upon those, because I think they're a catchall.
I think that these measures of chronic stress that
Shelley mentioned, cortisol,
allostatic load, I think those have promise, too, especially because they are so
readily, easily measured, typically from EHR records.
Many patients have those markers
already measured within their EHR.
And so I think that there's promise for those as well.
What I'm super interested in trying to figure out or work with others is the
temporal dynamics, like how quickly does allostatic load change, right?
If blood pressure's a measure of it, that can change quite quickly.
There's other aspects of it that are more long term.
And same thing with some of these other measures of stresses, like how sensitive
are they to acute changes,
as well as durability to measure chronic exposure to social stressors.
So the answer is, I don't know.
All right. With that, thank you everyone for participating-
Thank you
... in this session. Thank you, Jesse.